[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's make way for our good buddy ross
tucker host of the ross tucker football
podcast
and works for cbs in westwood one he
joins us on the program let me uh let me
start off with baker mayfield
um what do you do you think the browns
eventually just pony up and give him
that big contract extension
no i don't think they're going to dan i
think they're smart enough
with kevin stefanski and andrew berry a
couple ivy league guys i might add
i think that they're smart enough to
realize that
baker is a good quarterback he's not a
great quarterback he's not worthy of one
of those contracts i mean i can name
15 quarterbacks off the top of my head
probably that are clearly better than
baker mayfield i think they're happy
with him as a starter
but the weird thing about quarterbacks
is there's like no middle ground yeah i
mean you're either getting over 40
million a year
or you're getting 10 million or less
it's just crazy and the guy's getting 28
million or 24 like jimmy garoppolo it's
just because he signed his contract
three years ago now and it got kind of
jumped over i don't see how you do that
i heard you earlier dan you made a
terrific point
nobody else can give him that money you
know like i don't think that there's a
team that's gonna say
oh yeah cleveland doesn't love him
enough to pay him but we're going to
there will always be draft picks there
will always be other guys that i think
you will covet more than baker mayfield
we keep talking about devaluing the
running back position and last night was
another example
i just don't see a team where you go we
got to get that running back there's
derrick henry and then there's a bunch
of other running backs i i like camaro
uh mccaffrey i would not have given him
an extension uh saquon barkley's not
going to get a contract extension i
could it doesn't matter at that position
do you think it will ever matter at that
position where you actually
waste a first round draft pick now i
know the steelers did
but you know do you do that a top 15
pick on a running back
well i don't like the top 10 or top 15
pick i don't mind down in the 20s i
think the real problem is when you give
them a huge second contract now clearly
as you reference dan
derrick henry is a difference maker i i
mean i've seen that guy in person i
didn't recognize him at first it was the
sec championship game i thought he was
at the end
i was like hey who's that guy they're
like that's derek henry i'm like that's
derek henry
and and dan you're older than me but i i
can't remember another
250 pound man
that was that fast i mean the other
night he was going just about 22 miles
per hour
which is the fastest of any nfl player
with the ball in their hands this year i
mean think about that
uh somebody said christian okoye krishna
coyote was pretty fast bo jackson was
crazy fast but bo jackson wasn't 250 but
anyway
you guys can debate that later in terms
of what you said about mccaffrey
you know the only thing i would say
about that dan is he is so valuable in
the passing game the panthers are 3-0 in
games he starts
and 0-3 in games he doesn't and he had
been so durable
until he signed that contract but your
overall point is a good one i mean i
think we saw last night again
offensive line means a great deal you
look at the best teams in the league you
look at the worst teams in the league
more often than not it directly
correlates to the quality or lack
thereof of the offensive line
you know i'm watching odell beckham last
night and i i know that he's not healthy
but
i
he's in the wrong system
okay that's what i don't understand now
granted they brought him in before they
brought in kevin stefanski but he just
doesn't fit that system
but do you still keep odell beckham just
because he still has that star power and
the defense at least has to acknowledge
that he's in the game
i think if the browns got a good offer
for him
they would strongly consider moving him
i just don't know who's going to do that
i mean with his injury history
especially the last couple years
and lack of production who wants to take
on that salary i don't think anybody
does
and honestly odell beckham jr is one of
those guys dan he kind of makes me sad
like he he's one of the
all-time what-ifs his first two years i
remember thinking
this guy could be like jerry rice like
his first two years
were incredible but then he started to
you know do all the get all these
personal foul penalties and then there
was the stuff off the field and you just
realized he wasn't gonna be like jerry
rice
and
i don't know how people will take this
but it just wasn't important enough to
him and i'm not criticizing him for that
i'd probably be just like odell you
could probably go to germany and get
like three million dollars to do some
endorsement over there like i'm not mad
at odell but he decided early on in his
career
that the off the field stuff
was pretty important to him and that's
okay it's his life
but i really thought he could be like an
all-time great it's been the off the
field distractions and the injuries that
have prevented him from really even
getting close to what he could have been
why are the dolphins
at least reportedly
trying to trade for desean watson
their owner is not very patient and
frankly i wouldn't be either i mean can
you i don't know how old stephen ross is
i think he's in his 70s let me just tell
you right now i'm going on record right
now
if i'm a billionaire in my 70s and i own
a sports franchise i'm not going to be
patient at all
i mean not even a little bit he's 80.
what's that he's 81
yeah
um
even more reason and that's why deshawn
watson
ultimately
is going to get traded because one of
these owners david tepper of the
panthers these guys are used to getting
what they want it must be infuriating to
be able to literally pay
for anything in life you want
other than winning other than having a
good quarter i mean these guys can call
their private jet and fly to paris
tonight if they want and do whatever
they want to do in paris but you can't
buy that in the nfl but they want it so
they're going to do what it takes to get
a quarterback that gives them a chance
to win championships because they have
big egos and they want to win
championships jared goff goes back to
los angeles and i guess he's going to
play with a chip on his shoulder
i i don't know how that feels when you
play with a chip on your shoulder going
into a game like this but it feels like
it's dangerous from the standpoint of i
want to try to do more
than what i probably should what do you
think so yeah so i don't know what that
is like for a quarterback
i can distinctly remember in 2002
after steve spurrier in washington
released me i actually started dan for
the cowboys like a month later
on thanksgiving against washington and i
distinctly thought about
if it's like a sweep to that side maybe
i could take a db
and run him right in the spurrier and
knock him over throw him in the spring
like i had that mental image
so i don't i don't know what you do as a
quarterback but as a lineman you think
about man there might be some way if i'm
near the sideline i can chuck a guy in
the spurrier's legs didn't work out very
hard to do very hard to pull off
by the way it's a wake forest at army
yeah wake forest undefeated this is a
sneaky good game that you got
well what's awesome about dan it's not a
great saturday of college football games
there's not a lot of great matchups so
everybody at noon the game is sold out
it's at mikey stadium it's sold out wake
forest
best season best start
since 1944. they're 4-0 in the acc
they're 6-0 they get a great chance to
win the conference with clemson being
down but army's tough especially at home
i absolutely
cannot wait for this game new tomorrow
cbs sports network could you start for a
division three team right now
that is a great question um
i don't think so man i mean i'm 255
pound now no but you know why
about a month ago
i was on army's field
and i thought you know what i want to
change up my workouts a little bit
i ran 1400 yards sprint stand but i was
just like jogging i wasn't like really
sprinting
my hamstrings were sore for three weeks
three weeks i never do anything like
that i think i you know what i could
probably start
at center or guard
for a bad div a really bad division
three team
and then for a good month to two months
after that game
be incredibly sore and mad at myself
have fun this weekend great to great to
see you buddy thank you always thanks
dan that's ross tucker host of the ross
tucker football podcast and uh covers uh
college football as well he called
florida atlantic and charlotte last
night for cbs sports network and then
big one tomorrow at noon it's wake
taking on army